many people were saved by the quick
reactions of teachers and students
culinary arts teacher ashley Kurth
sheltered dozens of students in her
classroom including David Hogg a senior
at Stoneman Douglas high David is a
student journalist who was in he was
interviewed his fellow classmates during
the shooting so with your message just
hiding together you would know and now
David Hogg and Ashley cars are seeing
each other for the first time since the
shooting and they join us from Parkland
good morning David this is your teacher
and I know this is the first who
welcomed you into her classroom and I
know this is the first time you've been
with her since then what do you want to
say to her thank you honestly you
because of her heroic actions she say
it's easily like a 60 students lives or
however many were in that classroom
in the sad part is she shouldn't have
had to this should never have happened
and that it's just it's unbelievable
they're not words to describe the amount
of gratitude that I feel Church chef
Kurt's heroic actions and in a matter of
I would say 30 seconds taking in all of
those students and fitting them in about
a hundred feet of square space is
something that nobody else that nobody
that isn't a true hero could do I know
chef Kurt I've heard you say you're not
a hero but clearly you are to a lot of
people a lot of family and friends are
certainly thanking you today and I read
that you said one of the hardest things
was you had at least 60 kids in your
room and then you had to shut the door
and tell people to keep running take us
to exactly what was going on and how
difficult this was for you well I mean
we're we we had just recently gone
through a training and I've been through
a live action shooter training at my
previous school and you know flight or
flight just takes place and I just
started grabbing as much kids as I could
in from from that one door and then I
ran over to the other side just to make
sure my other door was secured and I was
I remember I was shaking as I was trying
to put my key into the door my head was
sticking out and you could just see all
the kids pouring out of the freshmen
building just screaming terrified and I
quickly ran to the other door just to
grab as many as I could that were
running by and the ones that were still
running I just kept screaming out I'm
like keep running don't stop because at
that point I mean you were hearing
gunshots go off and it was ricocheting
with the sound off the other building
and we didn't know whether it was one
shooter or two and one of the boys that
initially ran into my room was like
there's two shooters on and the kids
were just it was very intense it feels
like it was like an hour but in reality
it was like thirty seconds and I
remember standing there with like after
my one friend Timmy reallyö came in with
her last two kids that were falling
behind it was like a lull in the amount
of kids were going through and I saw
another kid bunch rushing through and
I'm like I couldn't stand there and hold
the door anymore so I had to just shut
the door and just go into my office area
with them and we just started assessing
with the kids that were there we got my
laptop out and started taking down the
names of all the students that were
currently in the room and my faculty
members that were with me
so that
we had 65 kids shoved in my dry storage
closet in my office and in my laundry
area so it was and all you could hear is
just screaming and gunshots all around
and David your reaction was when you
took out your camera why why was that
your instinct after we realized this
wasn't a drill I knew that if I was
going to die with those around me I
wanted the voices of I wanted our voices
to carry on and precede the ages of time
because even if our souls couldn't our
stories could still have an impact and
caused some real change in this country
that is certainly something that we all
need right now exactly right David you
you are so poised and so articulate I've
seen many interviews with you one of the
most touching things I heard came from a
reporter at CBS after the last shooting
Steve Hartman said we pray we mourn we
repeat because it goes on and on and you
are so passionately called for change
this time what is it that you want what
is your message to the lawmakers to the
lawmakers I say work together no matter
what policy you support you guys are
politicians make some compromises get
some stuff done and keep doing it
actually keep your promises don't just
make false promises just so you can get
reelected actually follow through and
who knows maybe you'll save some
children's lives because the amount of
deaths that I've had to deal with with
my sister having three of her best
friends died and in numerous other
families that have to go home to silent
rooms for the rest of their lives with
no children is absolutely unacceptable
it's deplorable and something has to
change the policymakers in this country
must work together and I don't care if
you're a Republican or a Democrat these
are children's lives that's the end of
the line and if you want to have mental
health reform and you support that if
you want to have some if you want to
have universal background checks you
support that why not do both politicians
compromise and we can get this done
it's just a matter of overcoming our
political barriers in order to save
children's lives and in
way our future - it's an issue of those
okay Ashley curtain David hug thank you
so much